alors on va faire l'anti portrait
chinois chaud
alors belgique si vous étiez un pays
chaud ouais mais la thaïlande
vous êtes originaire de là-bas ouais
ouais
si vous étiez un film chaud emmanuel
s'est bien passé a beaucoup marc
emmanuel quand j'ai vu emmanuel ma
sexualité a changé si vous étiez une
boisson chaude un chocolat chaud vous
étiez une mer chaude
je retire pas les affaires on a dit
pardon alors la mer des caraïbes
ouais positive pour les caraïbes c'est
une confidence chaude
et
une amie qui me qui me jetterai dans le
wraith la première filiation si vous
étiez un vent chaud mais scirocco
souhaité une époque chaude 69
si vous étiez un plat chaud une grenade
demory au autobiographie si vous étiez
un match aux miens
comment il est alors très beau il a un
métier tout ça va turbuler lundi soir
qu'il avait tinée et l'abkhazie pourquoi
il vient pas parce qu'il est un métier
comment comment il s'appelle benjamin
danger n'est la mort ni dans si vous
étiez un souvenir chaude parce que là on
bouquin si vous étiez un objet chaud mon
scooter
ouais si vous étiez un artichaut hardy
chaud
charmant
elles sont nées à mélina micro marveaux
benjamin tenez benjamin attention à
belhadj ans est très bien donc benjamin
c'est vous donc l'homme show de notre
ami bénédicte martin ça doit pas être
facile tous les jours une grossesse
comme ça la maison fête commence
il ya un traducteur benjamin sérieux
quand vous faites c'est un sacré
pistolet quand même mais c'est
impossible c'est à dire que je suis
obligé de me battre toute et sainte
souline avec des gens ouais heureusement
je suis assez musclé donc je me défends
comme je peux vous dire qu'après un
bouquin comme ça beaucoup de mecs vont
se jeter sur elle en imaginant qu'elle
est chaude en sachant qu'elle est chaude
au le sou
l ex fiancé c'était si tu
martin